hi there steve kaufman here
bit shiny there um today i'm going to
talk about
introverts and language learning
do you need to be an extrovert in order
to learn languages
you know there are so many myths
surrounding language learning you need
to do this you need to be that you have
to be musical
you have to have an ear for music some
people have a talent i don't have a
talent i don't believe any of that i
don't believe you need to be an
extrovert to learn languages and i'll
tell you why
because language learning comes down to
the three keys and i've said it before
and i'll say it again
number one
attitude you have to be interested in
the language you have to like the
language you have to believe you're
gonna
achieve your goal and i'll just stay
with that for a second because it's very
important
if you're looking for something around
the house and you go looking in a closet
or through your different pants pockets
so you're looking for a key
if you're convinced that that the item
you're looking for is there you'll find
it
in many cases but if you're not really
sure that it's there you kind of
half-heartedly look and in the end you
don't find it so
your determine your belief that you can
achieve your goal is very important and
i think they're
very often the first time language
learning has a pro learner has a problem
because they've never done it before so
but that's one part of attitude
enthusiasm interest dedication so forth
attitude 70 of the battle
number two is time you have to spend the
time you have to spend a lot of time
language learning takes time it's not
three months to fluency it takes a lot
of time every day for many many months
or longer
and the third thing you have to do is
develop this ability to notice you have
to you know
so often people are stuck with the way
words are written in their own language
and they don't listen to how it's
pronounced in the new language they'll
constantly translate expressions from
their own language into the new language
they're not paying attention to how
things are said in the new language so
alertness attentiveness now none of
those three things the attitude
the willingness to spend the time and
the attentiveness to the language none
of those three things require you to be
an extrovert
introverts can just as easily have those
qualities
so you know and if i look
if i look for example at link at some of
our members
in our wonderful community many of whom
speak several languages many of whom
i've spoken to in a variety of languages
i wouldn't call some might be
extroverted a lot are introverts it's
irrelevant and
you know if we look at the sort of main
language learning activities
um
yeah an expert extrovert may want to get
out there and speak right away and not
worry about what he or she doesn't
understand and wants to show off the few
phrases that they have and that's all
good there's nothing wrong with that
i'm not
really an introvert but i don't do that
and that's not a necessary condition of
language learning
i derive immense enjoyment from
listening and reading and building up my
vocabulary building up my familiarity
with the language and these activities
which are so enjoyable to me
right now last two weeks i've been
listening to italian i've been listening
to podcasts and audio books and reading
and really getting into the language
deriving great enjoyment and thereby
refreshing my knowledge of italian
acquiring new
uh vocabulary and so forth and so on it
doesn't require me to be an extrovert
these are all introverted activities if
you want i'm communicating with the
language and through the language with
the culture but i'm not required to be
an extrovert to do that
my goal eventually is to speak and i
know that these activities improve my
ability to speak now an introverted
person
may be more inclined to be
you know afraid to expose
their
shortcomings in the language the
mistakes that they're going to make
maybe they're more afraid that they're
going to sound
you know less educated than they are
less intelligent than they are
is possible
but the solution nevertheless is to
engage in these
in
in my view
these input-based activities
build up their familiarity their
vocabulary their comprehension skills so
that when they
go to speak they will feel more
comfortable
because introverted people
don't necessarily
i see no evidence that introverts
are less capable in their own language
i see no evidence that they have a
smaller vocabulary that they read less
that they understand less well that
they're interested in fewer things
so if that's true of their own language
i think it will be equally true
of a foreign language of a second
language
and they may behave differently uh you
know in the new language they may
speak less
uh
you know at some gathering however
introverts
typically when they are very comfortable
they usually have a lot to say
a lot of things of substance to say
and devoting yourself to you know if
you're an introvert devoting yourself to
input-based activities such as we do at
link
lots of listing and reading and building
up your vocabulary
this is going to make you more
comfortable because when you go to speak
you will have better listening
comprehension a bigger vocabulary and
you'll be better able to defend yourself
and that's going to make you more
confident so
i think that that very often the idea is
that people who are extroverts and love
to talk that they're going to do better
i think initially you know it's a bit of
a tortoise and hair situation i think
they'd be more like the hair off the bat
they're speaking more quickly but in the
long run in terms of
all of the language skills
that we normally talk about listening
reading speaking writing vocabulary
accuracy all of these things i don't
think the extroverts have an advantage
so
that's my take on
whether
being an introvert is an obstacle to
language learning
i'll be very interested in hearing your
opinion and i'll remind you again that i
i want to hear your opinions but it
doesn't mean that i will agree with
these opinions and sometimes when i ask
for opinions and someone gets on and
makes a comment and then i don't agree
with that comment you know i've had this
sort of thing well if you didn't want my
opinion why did you ask for it kind of
thing i don't have to agree we can
exchange opinions i won't convince you
you won't convince me but it's
interesting to see a variety of opinions
so there you have it thanks for
listening
and uh look forward to hearing from you
bye